i just think that we lived some of our
lives today and of course
you've manifested me yeah i really exist
except in your mind everything yeah who
manifested my food poisoning
oh yeah i'm not i haven't eaten in two
days it may not have been food poisoning
because there is a horrible
gi virus going around starts with
vomiting had everything
and then some diarrhea follows but
mostly it's just you're washed out for
two days
okay so we just got back from the
philippines and i thought that maybe
it was something that i ingested there
maybe but i actually started getting
really sick yesterday so i don't think
it was the philippines
sudden vomiting oh it was just sudden
everything yeah yeah yeah
but is it narrow it's a noro is here in
hollywood it's actually volatilized off
the feces that our friends leave on the
streets
yeah but it's also there's been a
gastroenteritis going on she had more
diarrhea than you see dr ken on tv
i mean it was just like every other
doctor ken jong he does
pepsi commercials everything he has
diarrhea no i'm just saying he's
her diarrhea was as frequent as him
but when he did have a license he used
to sit in for me on love line
oh really because when he came on as a
guest i was like that is a smart dude
who knows his profession
he does it he knew what the hell he was
doing in my i feel bad that he gave up
his license he should have kept
practicing at least one day a week when
i was detoxing off a vicodin
he was the only guy i called and he
helped me through that he knows what
he's doing he's amazing super smart
so you think that you have some american
virus
well and then i had this brief moment of
paranoia because i was in the shower
and i was washing my [ __ ] and
something was protruding from it and i
pulled out
probably was undigested piece of food
but it might have been
immediately ignored not a tapeworm
asceros because yeah cause you can get
that over there yeah it's the most
common one in the philippines but then
it looked
flat and white and i was like wait what
is this
it's a proglider
is the most common character from the
movie
ketchup shows she's talking so i started
like googling just the incubation period
how long does it take to be a full-grown
worm and so i'm in the safe yeah it's a
long time
well she's a nurse i don't even know
she's not anymore no no no not license
that's why you know more than she's very
what how dare you
[ __ ] you he loves kendra i know so many
i hope she knows more she's a nurse yeah
no not anything
i shouldn't say that that's not i'm not
a nurse
having had that training and experience
it'll stay with your whole life
and and you'll know more that your
judgment will be different than other
people
just having had that experience yeah
when we were in seattle someone was
dying next to us oh yeah at a restaurant
and she saved his life
i'm sure that he was a woman because i
didn't look up because
what was i doing he was playing in in
his panic he freezes and instead he
turns to his gadgets and he was playing
bejeweled
so instead of saying i was like bobby
call
her yeah he 911 does this turns his back
continues to high score baby yeah well
done
and do you know why i played sir dr drew
do you know why i did that you're a
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
yes that's obvious right diagnosis yeah
but the also the reason why i do it in
those kind of situations
i think that i'll make the situation
worse right i'll get in the way yes
right i'll try to help her a lunge and
then trip and then fall on her heart
and she'll die whatever you know also
the third reason why is i don't want to
fill out any paperwork
right so if she dies i don't want to
answer any questions
right so you get you get why i didn't do
anything
but mostly because i just wouldn't be
helpful to the situation
so when your girlfriend asked for
something very specific
that be too much no did you ask me to
help dialing
nine one
did i do it no she knows basic cardiac
right she knows basic
life support and the first thing you do
is go who call 9-1-1
yeah she didn't know when you do when
you learn on resusci and you go first
thing you look around
yeah assess your resources call 911. you
never
no one ever says and when the guy turns
his back on you
yeah then you call ask somebody else to
doubt my wife touche but can i say this
for my defense yes i had so much faith
in her skills
wow right i thought that you know she's
well played sir
yeah thank you they're they're they're
in good shape but she saved that
person's life
and then her mom was choking here in the
living room
living room and she saved her life so
i've seen her in you know in real time
and full action
so um and he did make the situation
worse at that time he did call 9-1-1 on
my mom but
i don't think he was actually
formulating any real sentences he was
just screaming into this
is your sister a nurse too my sister is
a great nerd she's still a nurse
she's actually the the head nurse of the
county jails and stuff
oh my god that is a hard job so she has
the the
at the carriage or at the jail ward at
the county she has she's the head nurse
at the
um van nuys jail over here not twin
towers yeah all the
the i think those the super um troubled
ones get sent to twin towers
so you know what what her job entails
her sisters oh i do
yeah it's crazy she sees some stuff and
she has to empty
people who have just stabbed their wives
to death things like that
and they're not they're not cuffed
either she has to medically
she has to see them um with the cops and
sitting behind and her
just talking to them like regular people
and she has to be absolutely
not biased and just be very objective
yeah
you know just as a lay person um
whenever i
think of a job that entails dealing
with life-and-death situations you
turned your back in place i i played
because of the fact that it's just so
real and shocking to me that like i'm
just one of those guys i panic like she
when we first went to the philippines
not this time but the last time years
ago she had a heart
attack she had arrhythmia and i had to
call
you know we had to get the ambulance and
we had carried her to the thing
we went to the hospital i mean it's just
you know i've been in situations with
her where it's like
it's difficult or lonely one of those
um no i actually have two things i have
an svt that i got an ablation for
but it was not wolf park it wasn't a
re-entrant thing because um i think that
wolf they can see that
um through imaging right different yeah
and then i also
have an occasional run of um
quite complex yeah i actually have a
wide complex as well but i have this
weird run of v-tac
randomly absolutely that i started
saying something
i was an athlete for 15 years i was a
swimmer i swam division one and then
afterwards
i think that did they check you for the
genetics of the myosin abnormalities
oh my god because that's a lot of like
southeast asian men die from
did they catch the v-tac do they they
caught the v-tac during the ablation
they were able to
catch everything oh my god oh my lord
i'm shaking my finger and popping it's
like that's real stuff i know it's real
i love it so when people say oh i've got
palpitations
you should laugh at them
the reason why i'm laughing it's like if
like wolverine
showed his claws right when people think
about wolverine and you eat
the the legend of wolverine you go ah
does he and then when he shows you the
claws
so you just showed me that you're a real
doctor oh okay oh
yeah and so what i was trying to follow
you bobby yeah yeah yeah i know
i know you were and so um when you were
you know throwing down heat just now
with information
i thought wow he's legit that's all
that's why i was laughing